Hi class, this
lecture will focus on
allergens and allergic
rhinitis. And this
will be a very short
lecture. Most of it
should be a review,
and I have included
the questions for
review in this set.
So I will briefly
describe histamine and
the physiology of
the H1 receptor. I'll
distinguish between first
and second generation
antihistamines and
the differences in
their adverse effects.
And there'll be other
drugs that can manage
allergic reactions
like epineprin, which
is EpiPen, Chromlin,
Montelukas. So
I'll describe their
mechanisms in this
brief lecture as well.
so histamine comes
from decarboxylation of
the amino acid known
as histidine and it
is produced by both
the mast cells and the
basophils as you see
in this picture and
it's IgE mediated
okay and histamine now
as you see here once
it's released it's
going to have an effect
on the airway the
smooth muscle will become
contracted okay and
that's why with some
of the symptoms that
you might see patients
may experience some
difficulty in in
breathing wheezing and
with respect to the
blood vessels there's
going to be some
vasodilation that occurs
and there's also going
to be the capillaries
are going to be
permeable as you can
see here and there's
going to be some
leakage out. So you
may see some edema when
a patient has an
allergic reaction. And
some of the symptoms
that we'll see in the
next slide can
actually point to that.
And then with
respect to the immune
system, histamine has
some regulation there
where there may be
some effects on the
T cells, okay? And, of
course, some effects
also on neutrophils
and asanophils.
Once histamine
is released, some
of the classic
symptoms will be,
of course, itching
and uticaria,
which is really
described as hives.
And maybe you've
experienced that if maybe
you got exposed, say,
to poison ivy. There
can be flushing. and
as I mentioned the
hypotension is due to
the vasodilation and when
the body senses low
blood pressure there's
going to be a somewhat
of a release of
sympathetic stimulation
and you'll see and
this will go next year
when you talk cardiac
and the baroreceptor
reflex mechanism When
the body senses low
blood pressure, high
sympathetics is going
to induce tachycardia.
And then, as I mentioned,
bronchospasm, due to
the fact that there
is constriction
in the airway,
angioedema is
really what we see
here. The
patient will get
swelling of the
lips, the tongue.
And angioedema is also
related to bradykinin.
And bradykinin we'll
discuss again next year
when we talk about
ACE inhibitors. ACE
inhibitors are commonly
used for hypertension.
And by blocking
ACE, you increase
bradykinin. And some
people will get sensitive
to this effect and
they'll get the
swelling of the
lips and the tongue.
And usually for
that, we would stop
the medication and
give them something
that blocks the
receptors. and those
are known as ARBs or
Sartans. So I'm not
going to complicate
that right now,
but that will be
something that we will
discuss when we do
cardiac next semester.
And then histamine does
produce wakefulness
and it makes sense
because we have
done throughout the
semester blockers of
the H1 receptor and
we know one of the
things that happens
if we're talking
about the hypothalamus
and the brain is that
especially the ones
that are highly
lipophilic and cause
the blood-brain
barrier, they're going
to cause a sedation.
And then another
thing to understand is
that there are receptors
called H2 receptors,
and these are going
to have an effect
on the enteral
chromophane-like cells
of the stomach, where
when this receptor
is stimulated, it's
going to allow the
release of stomach
acid from the parietal
cells. And there is a
group of medications
that block the H2
receptors, and those
are known as famotidine,
which is pepcid,
rinitidine, which is
Zantac. And again,
we'll talk about them
more in depth next
semester, because the
receptor mechanism
is going to be G
-stimulatory. And I'll
tell you in a minute
what the H1 receptors
are as we get
through this lecture.
So here we are.
The alpha 1, the M3, and
the H1 are
going to be GQ.
So again, we have
done this throughout
the semester. and
it's important that
we keep reviewing
this because it is a
concept that is
tested on boards where
the alpha subunit is
going to detach from
the beta and gamma
and now what takes
takes away is an
enhancement of phospholipase
c and that's going
to activate ip3 and
dag and that's going
to allow the stored
calcium to become free
and you're going to get
continued activation
by protein kinases.
Okay, so I've
explained already with
the alpha-1 receptor
agonists like
phenylephrine that
we can use for
patients that need
nasal decongestion.
There's going to be
vasoconstriction,
and that allows
the fluids from the
nose to kind of pass
through, and you
feel better, you
feel less congested.
But if you are agonizing
alpha-1 receptors
on the arteriole
and through this
mechanism of getting
an increase of calcium,
that's going to
cause contraction
of the smooth muscle
of the arteriole and
that's going to
raise blood pressure.
Okay, so that's a good
way to kind of connect
receptor physiology
to drug mechanism.
So the antihistamines
are going to be
classified as first
generation. they are
lipophilic enough to
cross the blood-brain
barrier and they will
cause drowsiness.
And that's going to be
something like
diphenhydramine,
doxylamine. And I did
mention this and their
benefit in the sedative
hypnotic lectures
that they can actually
cause sedation
and it can make people
sleep. The second
generation are non
-drowsy. They're not
lipophilic. They don't
across the blood-brain
barrier, so you can use
something like, say,
loratidine if you
need to take an exam.
You're coming to school
and taking an exam.
The other thing is that
the first generation
do have the ability
to block muscarinic
receptors, while the
second generation
do not. So, if you had,
say, an elderly male
that had benign
prosthetic hypertrophy,
A first-generation
drug like
diphenhydramine would
worsen this condition
when you consider
the muscarinic
3-block in the
urinary bladder.
Something, again,
like loratadine,
since it's void of
muscarinic block,
would not have this
issue. So you would
recommend loratadine
to that patient.
so here we are and I
have in this mini lecture
put everything into
charts because it may
be a little bit easier
and again as you can
see the first
generation h1 block and
anticholinergic so when
we talk about motion
sickness what is very
special if we're talking
about the vestibular
apparatus what's present
there is going to be
an h1 and a muscarinic
receptor so if you're
blocking say with
diamond hydronate
that's the reason why if
you're going on a cruise
you would use that
medication because
it's going to block the
receptors in the vestibular
so you're not going
to have that balance
problem that's going
to cause you to feel
nauseous on a boat ride
okay But as you can
see, the adverse effects
would limit in some
patients. Yes, if you
wanted to get some
sleep, you can take
something like Benadryl
right before bed. But
understand, if you are
a glaucoma patient, that
muscarinic block can
cause your pupils to
dilate and that's going
to prevent the outflow
of the fluid there and
that can complicate
somebody that has
narrow-angled glaucoma.
Weight gain, we mentioned
probably a couple
of times in the
semester that if you
block H1 receptors
in the hypothalamus,
you're going to get
activation of AMP kinase,
and that signal
actually causes an
increase in appetite,
and you're also going
to get an increase
in fat accumulation.
So weight gain is
going to be common with
these. the urinary
retention the constipation
the dry mouth dry
eyes again due to
muscarinic blockade mainly
the m3 receptors the
increase in av node
action has to do with
the fact that in the
heart there's m2 receptors
when you block you're
going to increase
heart rate and you're
av node action and
that can lead to some
tachycardia promethazine
and kyproheptadine
have the same actions
that they block h1 and
muscarinic receptors
but promethazine also
has some alpha 1 block
and some d2 block so
now going to think
about alpha 1 block that
is going to cause now
orthostasis because
now when you block
the alpha 1 receptors
and you get up rather
quickly you're not
going to get the pooling
of the blood as quickly
to the extremities
that you need and
patients can end up
getting dizzy and falling
the other thing is
promethazine does have
some d2 block okay
and that would be now
that you could have a
patient say that has
parkinson's disease
experience more tremors,
more bradykinesia,
because you're
thinking about
D2 block in the
nigrostriadium.
Ciproheptadine has a little
bit less of the alpha
-1 block, but it does
have serotonergic
blockade along with h1
and anticholinergic
mechanism so ciproheptadine
if you remember this
was the one that we
could give if the
patient ended up having
serotonin syndrome
remember serotonin syndrome
was when on board you
have two serotonergic
drugs like maybe an
SSRI and linezolid
or a tricyclic with
tramadol and the patient
is going to have a fever
high fever actually
they're going to
have some degree of
autonomic instability
like high heart rate
they're going to have GI
symptoms like diarrhea
and they're also going
to be having myoclonic
episodes where they
may end up getting
a seizure so again you
remove the drug you
do supportive care
and you give something
like ciproheptadine one
thing i will say with
the weight gain that
we should mention is
that sometimes when
patients say were treated
for certain cancers
and you got some degree
of the patient having
a loss of appetite
sometimes you might see
maybe kyproheptadine
being used for that
purpose. There are
other drugs, because
again, we would still
worry about the
anticholinergic effects and
the D2 block, but that
could be another option.
So I just want to
just mention that. So
now we have the
second generation,
and sometimes
you may see that
fexofenidine and
desloratidine
and levocetirazine are
considered to be
third generation.
Not much there with
the desloratadine and
olivocetirazine they're
they're in antemors
okay so i don't want
to get into the the
structure and the medicinal
chemistry but i want
to say that the second
generation their
claim to fame is that
they're not sedating
because they don't cross
the blood brain barrier
the other thing is they're
not anticholinergic
so that bph patient
that patient that
has glaucoma, that
patient that doesn't like
the drying effects of
say diphenhydramine
would benefit
from one of these.
However, one thing
to know is that these
drugs, since there's
no muscarinic
block, you won't be
able to give them if
you're going on a
cruise ship because they
don't have any effects
in the vestibular
apparatus. They
are very good, as I
said, if you have
seasonal allergies and
you need to drive or
operate machinery.
Other modifiers
of histamine,
though not directly,
may include some of
the drugs that I'm
going to talk about.
Number one is going
to be epineprin, and
this is known as EpiPen.
And this mechanism
is interesting because
this is the one
that has agonism at
both beta 1 and beta 2
receptors, alpha 1
and alpha 2 receptors.
So the issue here is,
you know, what's the
difference between
norepinephrine and
epinephrine? And why
do we give epinephrine
when the patient has
an allergic reaction?
Norepinephrine does
have beta 1, alpha
1, and to an extent
alpha 2 agonism. So
it can help with
the fact that that
patient is is getting
vasodilation but one
thing that epineprin
has that norepineprin
doesn't is the beta
-2 agonist effect
so if you gave
norepineprin that might
help as i mentioned
the lowering of blood
pressure but it
would not reverse the
bronchoconstriction. So
that's why it's EpiPen,
okay? Because of the
beta-2 agonist effect.
Beta-2, remember, is
present on the lungs.
If you agonized,
you're going to get
relaxation of the
smooth muscle, okay?
And that makes sense
because if you block a
beta-2 receptor, say
with propanolol, you're
going to get more
bronchoconstriction,
okay? Some of the adverse
effects of epineprin
is that you're going to
get some palpitations,
and that's going
to probably be due
to the beta-1 effects.
You're going to get
hypertension, and that's
due to the alpha-1.
And if you're increasing
sympathomimetic
effects, you're going to
get some degree
of CNS excitement,
anxiety, things
of that nature.
Beta-2 agonists are used
commonly now for asthma,
COPD.
And the reason that
these now are widely
used is because they
are going to be specific
for beta-2. So in other
words, if you were
thinking of somebody
with hypertension,
you wouldn't worry so
much about the beta
2 agonist because
they're not doing much
they're not doing anything
to the alpha receptors
you would not worry
about the hypertension
same thing with the
some of the newer
beta 2 agonists they
don't really have much
of an effect on beta
1 albuterol might
and that's why you know
albuterol when patients
use it as rescue
because it's a short
-acting beta agonist.
Sometimes they may get
palpitations, but some
of the newer drugs
that we use to maintain
the person, like
salmeterol, which is
a long-acting beta
agonist, does not have
this effect because it's
more selective for
the beta-2 receptors.
There is a couple of
other drugs, is chromalin
and needle chromo.
And then these two,
ketotypin and lodoximide
that are given as
an ophthalmic drop,
an eye drop. So if the
patient was experiencing,
say, an allergic
reaction that gave
them watery eyes, this
would be topical. But
chromalin and needle
chromo, They are
there to stabilize the
mast cells. So when
IgE is detected, these
medications, if they're
on board, they're
stabilizing the mast
cells. So you're not
getting the release
of histamine. However,
once an allergic reaction
happens due to that
mechanism, these drugs
won't work. These
are preventative. They're
very safe. They're
inhaled or used
ophthalmically. they're not
absorbed but these are
very ideal if you're
going to a place where
you might be triggered
from say i don't
know pet dander okay
they are going to
prevent once you have the
allergic reaction no you
have to use something
else to now get rid of
the allergic response
Okay, so that's
something to understand.
And then a couple
of things that
need to be understood
is the receptor
physiology of the
beta receptors.
So these are G
-stimulatory, okay?
I said before that
the H2 receptor
is also G
-stimulatory, okay?
And what happens
when you have a beta
-2 agonist, Now
you're going to get,
as you can see, an
increase ultimately
of adenyl cyclase
and an increase in
cyclic AMP and an
increase in protein
kinase A. And that's
going to, again,
increase calcium
activated
potassium channel
activation.
There's going to be
ultimately a decrease
in myosin light chain
kinase. So when you're
giving this, what
you're going to end up
doing due to this
mechanism on myosin light
chain kinases, you're
not going to get
contraction, you're going
to get more relaxation.
Or we like to say in lung
physiology,
bronchodilation.
Methylxanthins,
I'm not going to
talk much about
because they'll be
covered in the
respiratory module.
These drugs like
theophylline,
which is a bronchodilator,
they will achieve
the same overall
mechanism that a direct
B2 agonist does. But
here, they're inhibiting
an enzyme known as
phosphodiesterase 3.
And when you block that
enzyme, you enhance
adenyl cyclase and
protein kinase A.
So these are direct
and these are indirect
because they block
this enzyme that breaks
it down. So if
you're blocking this
enzyme, then this has
the ability to happen.
Ecosinoids are important.
I'll talk about
the glucocorticoids because
they stop everything
from the beginning.
But you realize
that once this does
start to happen, you have
two outcomes. You have
the cyclooxygenase
pathway, and that's
going to involve the
formation of prostaglandins,
which are going
to be blocked with
something like NSAIDs.
Aspirin is specifically
going to bind
thromboxane, and that's
important because
that irreversible
action is going to stop
platelet aggregation.
But on the other side
is the lipooxygenase
pathway, and we do
have a drug that will
specifically bind
lipooxygenase, and
that's known as zeluton,
and sometimes that's
given for asthma.
And then we have the
leukotriene receptor
antagonist, and those
are known as the
leukast family. Pran
-leukast, Zephyr-leukast,
and the main one
is Monty-leukast.
That's given as
sinulaire. It can be given
in pediatric patients
at a smaller dose.
And although it's
used to treat asthma,
it can have an effect
at improving allergies.
And it does have some
benefit in maintaining
somebody who has an
allergy to aspirin.
And this is an
interesting phenomenon
because when you're
allergic to aspirin, by
the way, you should
avoid NSAIDs. And the
idea here is, you know,
what is happening?
If you were allergic
to aspirin or NSAIDs,
the mechanism is that
there's going to be
a shunting towards the
leukotriene pathway.
And if that is activated,
the leukotriene
pathway, then
you're going to get
bronchoconstriction. You
may get some wheezing,
obviously, maybe hives.
So you will use one of
these blockers to stop
that reaction. Okay,
so going back to
glucocorticoids, they're
going to stimulate
the synthesis of
lipocortin and that will
inhibit phospholipase
A2 and that's going
to be the starting
point which involves
arachnidonic acid.
So that's why glucocorticoids
stop everything
from the beginning.
They can be used for
inflammatory conditions
like IBD or rheumatoid
arthritis or they can
be used in an acute
episode of asthma. And
as I said, everything
that we use glucocorticoids
is acute. You
do not want to stay on
a glucocorticoid for
a long period of
time. So number one,
glucocorticoids, fat-soluble
vitamins, and hormones
like thyroid and the
*** hormones follow
this pathway. The drug
binds to a receptor
inside the cell, which
has been kept stable
with heat shock proteins.
When the drug binds,
those heat shock
proteins dissociate and
what will happen is
you're going to get a
dimerization reaction
that continues into the
nucleus on response
elements. In this case,
this is a glucocorticoid
response element.
And when this
happens, you're going
to activate messenger
RNA to produce
proteins and the
ultimate response.
So it may take a
little bit for this to
happen. okay but the
idea here is we don't
want to go more than
10 to 14 days at
maximum because you
know by now that
glucocorticoids do have
a negative effect number
one on growth they
can decrease growth
hormone secretion and
that can be problems
in say a pediatric
patient and this is
why in earlier
times, if a child had
asthma and you gave too
much glucocorticoid,
sometimes you needed
to, they were probably
shorter in stature
than their peers.
It's going to affect
this whole idea of
metabolism. You're going
to get fat redistribution
in the abdomen, increased
gluconeogenesis,
which can complicate
type 2 diabetics.
With respect to, say,
the cardiovascular
system in the kidney,
there's going to be more
of a recovery of
sodium and water with
glucocorticoids, and that
can exacerbate somebody
who's hypertensive.
In the bone, these
drugs can increase
osteoclasts which break down
bone and the other
thing is they have an
effect a negative effect
on vitamin d if more
vitamin d is being
excreted then you don't
have enough vitamin
d to allow calcium to
be absorbed from the
gi tract so this is why
we don't want to give
glucocorticoids too
much they're there for
the acute episode and
then the patient is
weaned off and started
on something else to
maintain them. And the
weaning has to do with
the fact that if you
discontinue the
glucocorticoids too fast,
you're going to get HPA
suppression. And that
can lead to an exacerbation
of the patient's
symptoms that you
were trying to treat.
So here we go now with
the first question. A
51-year-old airplane
pilot presented for his
annual physical exam
and complained of
excessive itchy watery eyes
and sneezing associated
with seasonal
allergies which of the
following is the most
appropriate drug for this
patient so he's an
airline pilot and he has
allergies so obviously
we don't want this
patient to be falling
asleep during our flight
okay so we have to
look for something that
is probably a second
generation antihistamine
is it ciproheptadine
and the answer is no
this is the one that
has some serotonergic
block but it also has
dopamine and muscarinic
and histamine block
and the histamine block
is first generation.
So this would be a no.
Diphenhydramine
has muscarinic, an
H1 block. It's
sedative because it
crosses the blood
-brain barrier.
Epineprin would not
be the right choice
for him. He's not having
an allergic reaction.
And remember, too
much epineprin can
create problems now
with cardiovascular
effects. This is the
one that's going to be
stat, intramuscular for
somebody that maybe,
you know, consumed
shrimp and is allergic
to seafood or maybe
got stung by a bee.
Fexofenadine is
considered to be a second
or sometimes a third
generation antihistamine.
It does not cross the
blood-brain barrier
because it's not
lipophilic. It has no
muscarinic block. this
is the best choice.
And then prednisone,
again, would not
be used for having
seasonal allergies.
This would be more
for a patient that
maybe has an acute
asthma or an acute
inflammatory response
like RA, IBD,
Crohn's. So D here
is the best answer.
A 43-year-old male
with a history of
seasonal allergies
develops wheezing,
chest tightness, and
bronchoconstriction
soon after
starting aspirin
to prevent
cardiovascular disease.
He has administered
Monty Lukas, which of
the following describes
the mechanism of
the drug. So he's
taking aspirin as
prophylactic for cardiac
because aspirin will
bind thromboxane,
which is a platelet
aggregator. But he does
develop some wheezing
and chest tightness.
And this is especially
true. If you have
a history of, say,
asthma, or you have a
history of allergies,
you are more prone
to have allergic
reactions with aspirin
and NSAIDs because,
again, those are on
the cyclooxygenase
pathway. There's
going to be a shunting
towards the leukotriene
pathway, and
that's going to
cause this response.
So Montelukast
came lower. It
doesn't block
lipooxygenase.
That's going to be
zeluton. If anything,
this is going to be the
LTD-4 blocker, okay?
And that's going to
be the correct answer.
A serotonin-2A antagonist,
that is something
we covered earlier
in the semester.
Those are going to
be the drugs that are
considered to be
atypical antipsychotics,
dipsychotics like
rispidone or lansapine,
clozapine, which
is used for
refractory cases
of schizophrenia.
Those are not really
fitting here. Those
are going to be drugs
that we use for those
patients that have
bipolar depression or
some schizophrenia. And
with those, again, And
the block in the
nigrostriadium doesn't
really include D2 block.
So you're not going
to have as much
Parkinson-like effects
with those drugs. If
anything, you may have
weight gain and you may
have metabolic changes
like hyperglycemia
or hyperlipidemia. So
this doesn't fit
here. an m3 antagonist
um with respect to the
drugs we talked about
here they may be
appropriate say if you had
a patient that maybe
was going on a car
ride or on a boat ride
because the m3 and h1
receptors are in the
vestibular area and
that block would help
regulate balance and
then inhibitor of
phospholipase A2, that's
going to be a glucocorticoid.
So if we talked
about prednisone
or betamethasone or
fluticason, that would
be the best answer. So
this is Monty Lukas'
mechanism of action.
A 17-year-old female
developed itching
soon after consuming
shrimp. Minutes later,
she became anxious
that her chest was
tight and she starts
gasping for air she
was administered a
drug and with minute
within minutes the
episode resolves which of
the following
describes the receptor
which reversed her
difficulty breathing so
here there's all
receptors here um so
looking at the choices
well first of all let's
see what she's having
she's having an
anaphylaxis because
she consumed seafood.
So most likely
the one that
worked within
minutes is an
intramuscular
injection of EpiPen.
So EpiPen, going back to
the mechanisms
of epineprin,
epineprin has
it all. It has
alpha-1 agonism, alpha-2,
beta-1, and beta-2.
okay so looking at
the choices um we have
we have two that
can fit so let's see
the ones that are
not it's not a beta 1
antagonist the beta
1 antagonist that's
selective would
be something like
metoprolol that we use
a lot in cardiology
it decreases cardiac
output it decreases
sympathomimetic action
this one doesn't
fit okay if we had
somebody with chf or
had an mi that would
be appropriate. In
fact, a beta-1
antagonist might, you
know, worsen the
situation to an extent.
Mass cell stabilizer,
no, because these
are drugs that prevent
an allergic response.
You'd have to take
it as a preventative.
And then an M3 agonist
is a no. If anything,
an M3 agonist would
probably cause more
bronchoconstriction,
it would cause more
bradycardia, and an M3
agonist would probably
cause those wet
symptoms, like urination,
diarrhea,
lacrimation, salivation.
So now it's like,
what do we choose?
Because both of them
are considered to
be receptor mechanisms
of epineprin.
But we're asking
which reversed her
difficulty breathing,
and that is the beta-2.
Beta-2, two lungs,
one heart. So
beta-1 receptors
are on the heart,
beta-2 receptors
are on the lung.
This agonized
those receptors,
so she was able
to breathe again.
An alpha-1 agonist
would help if she was
going into some type
of vasodilatory effect.
Sometimes that can
manifest. If we were
talking about, say,
norepinephrine, a patient
going into shock, so an
alpha-1 agonist would
pick up the blood
pressure, so to speak.
If the question asked
about vasoconstriction,
then we would choose
the alpha-1 agonist
because that can cause
vasoconstriction.
So the best answer here
is the beta-2 agonist
because we're talking
about the breathing
part. So that has to
be beta-2. It's on the
lungs. If you agonize
those receptors,
you're going to relax a
smooth muscle. And now
the patient can breathe
again. The opposite
of that would be a
beta 2 antagonist. So
something like
propanolol, which is non
-selective, and I mentioned
that, would actually
have a negative effect
on breathing because
it's blocking those
receptors in the lungs.
So that's it
for now. Thank
you for your attention.
It is a shorter
lecture, but there's a
lot of important
concepts that I think
you need to review.
If there's anything
you need, please
let me know. If not,
have a great day and
I'll see you soon.